On January 1, at zero one minute
Moscow time, artillery of the Armed Forces was
struck by six rockets of the
Hymars multiple launch rocket system
at the point of temporary deployment of one of the
Russian military units in the area of ​​​​the
settlement of Makeevka
two rockets were intercepted
by air defense officers on duty
four rockets with a
high-explosive high-explosive combat missile  partly hit the building in
which Russian military personnel were located
detonation of warheads of
Hummers rockets collapsed
ceilings
Unfortunately, during the analysis of the rubble of
reinforced concrete structures, the number of
dead of our comrades increased to
89 among the dead, Deputy
Regiment Commander Lieutenant Colonel Bachurin, all the
affected families of the dead
military personnel are provided with all the
necessary assistance and support
Currently, a commission is working to
investigate the circumstances of the incidents,
but it is already obvious that the main
reason for the incident was the inclusion and
mass use
This factor allowed the enemy to
locate and determine the coordinates of the
location of military personnel for
launching a missile attack, despite
the
ban on mobile phones
in the zone of
reach of the enemy’s
weapons